so Ellen everybody I know my perception
of Ellen is Ellen is the greatest nicest
lady just the best comes out on top
shows like a white Oprah giving away
[ __ ] all the time everybody gets gifts
also much like white Oprah apparently
not that great of a person in real life
and I had to heard this once or twice
before but I kind of just dismissed it
as like sometimes you hear these little
Hollywood rumors and you don't it's like
how seriously can I take it yes and then
someone started a threat on Twitter that
was basically just I'll donate $2 for to
some charity for every shitty story I
get of Ellen Ellen just a story of Ellen
being me and he got like thousands of
responses or something crazy like that
and then he ended up taking like 150 or
something that sounded believable yeah
and some of them you rounded up to 300
and then in the 600 I said now it's a
little unfair because you're rewarding
people for saying the shitty stories but
I was speaking I was speaking of certain
people whose opinions I respect and they
were telling me that a lot of these that
he heard were absolutely true and from
sources that he believes now it's
interesting that all the sudden that
people are coming out now I think this
what happens when their people are
concerned and we're not gonna go back to
business as usual like when you feel
like you could use Ellen for your career
yeah then you're with it when you're
like oh we're not going back to normal
then we might as well blow the whole
thing up yes and I think that's what's
happening cuz you see a lot of like
people in the industry like people that
are respected like respected did you
hear anything beyond these stories are
true or meaning did you hear anything
additionally did you get any other
inside info I I just got inside info did
that these stories are I can't say the
true cuz I'm not there but of people we
know so it's not some random person
writers and a PA on the show yeah it was
like a writer or comic that we know both
of us okay and we're like why would she
lie about that yeah and she she is
interesting why would she lie about that
I want to get it up because I want to
read some yeah the horse I heard about
it was a somebody and this is actually
about another guy he wrote for
Gordon and then somebody was like was
how was he he's like nah he's not that
nice and everybody the guys really he
seems so nice he goes it's the same [ __ ]
Ellen does you know you seem really nice
on camera than all cameras not like that
and this is what we're working with yeah
but then I was just like really Ellen
and he was like yet when the cameras
ain't on Ellen is here are some of the
things that the accusations made against
on TV writer Benjamin Simon replied to
Porter Street with she is a sensitive
nose so everyone must chew gum from a
bull outside her office before talking
to her and if she thinks you smell that
day you have to go home and shower
reasonable that's fine I think what
happens is like she's the king or queen
or [ __ ] bull dyke I don't know what
you call her kingdom so when you have
your kingdom you decide the rules yeah
that David Letterman used to have a rule
even if you're like a guest on the show
nobody walks down the hall nobody's in
the hall when he's walking down the hall
which in my mind people were making an
[ __ ] thing but I'm like he probably
wants his time before the show you know
what I wanted to rub money to rub up to
him want to get in the zone that's
another thing it's like what I'll try
doing when I'm sorry I will try to do is
like we'll make arguments for why these
are reasonable and yeah cuz I'm hearing
them I'm like but sometimes there are
good arguments for people acting what is
perceived as Dickon now I won't defend
all these that's the one that I was like
I guess like the only issue I had with
that is they don't that she don't make
people take gum right before they enter
the office of the building like usually
have good breath for everybody in the
building like we've all worked with
people whose breath [ __ ] stink yeah
and then you got to talk to this guy all
day yeah right there's this guy fall
around stalling me remember that writer
dude who wrote gangster American
Gangster yeah the whole wait man were
you working with those bad all white got
it wrote American Gangster he was
following us following Charlamagne
around to write a New York Times article
and this guy would close talk to you and
his [ __ ] mouth stunk his breath stunk
he smell like tuna sandwiches it was
horrendous and I remember this entire
time going like I wish there was some
way where I could
force him to clean his mouth and I'll
say this about that story if did he did
that I'd be like that's great did he's
great it he's the best if there's a
diddy story I'm on board yeah I guess we
already have it in our minds he's kind
of an [ __ ] and he's brutally honest
and all that but like I'm like yeah
that's did he and also she framed it
like this she was like everybody here
deserves to work in a environment yeah
this is conducive to conversation so you
must take a bite of this gum when you
come in so your breath is good sometimes
you don't realize your breath is good
but you must do it and also if you smell
bad you're not showering you're
insulting the people who work around you
yep easy sale is easy great you tell
them in a nice way you don't force them
and go home and shower now you got it
cuz that's like telling everybody office
hey this person stinks today go to [ __ ]
hole now or you can nicely bring them to
the side and be like you know is
everything okay and like just what are
they going through some they depress or
some [ __ ] like that like don't embarrass
them in front of the whole staff that
[ __ ] works but also sensitive knows it's
it's a woman like everybody in here got
a girl and they got some weird and
probably we have one too but I'm two
sexes to admitted they got some weird
personal quirk that you're like ah
that's just some [ __ ] she does I mean
she's just she does this thing she hates
this thing whatever like I don't call
her out in public no I wouldn't call my
girl up but every girl has he's like
idiosyncratic like I was just a weird
thing is she got a strong as no she
can't and if you're a [ __ ] worth you
know hundreds of millions of dollars and
[ __ ] smells to you you sent
home dad I don't I don't think a new
staff member was told every day she
picks someone different to really hate
it's not your fault just suck it up for
the day and she'll be mean to someone
else the next day they didn't believe it
but it ended up being entirely true that
I can believe and I do know people like
that now that'd be me to everyone think
about it into one sink at the office
because that's bullying and we we won't
stand for bullies on any level oh you're
a bully you bully me all the time
boy you son bully bow novice you're a
bully shut the [ __ ] up and do the next
week holy moly this guy goes on cruel
he's got telling he can't wait to trash
[ __ ] not in trash anybody only the
guy who just said hey look at my weed I
have no talent
I'm a grow up I was gonna tell drew
needs to start [ __ ] getting at these
[ __ ] more treat it like the
front row it just shows anybody can do 9
is you say yeah marked be the most
vicious yo maybe she not everybody yo
here's the thing yeah but he says that
others breath in the bag like they don't
really hit I should I really this is
like yes I'm gonna roast people and I'm
gonna [ __ ] with them but at the same
time you understand like a lot of times
these people when they join the cause
got talent thing they're like you know
man is so great to meet you I love your
chest concept like nobody's a fan and
respect Simon Cowell you know me like no
one looks at Sonic a yeah you're great
at what you do what do you do again yeah
they don't love him beyond America's Got
Talent yeah they're like you have an
opportunity for me I want to use you
saying you're the one who could get away
with it or maybe Alex [ __ ] with them
also it's hard if like somebody's
singing and they're nervous and it's
like I'm sweet it's like you know I
don't want to [ __ ] on this person but a
guy who's like a bro I love you look at
my weed they did luck yourself y'all
know they get it these are you'll get it
the other thing is like I truly want
people to do their best
yeah so if I started out trashing them
100% well but if their [ __ ] sucks then
we go after ya you know unless it's a
delusional girl and she's just singing
crazy then that's just fun to LA so
everyone requests - come on crow - got
ya
ok I worked uh real food daily
served her at brunch she wrote a letter
to the owner and complained about my
chipped nail polish not that it was on
her plate but just that it was on my
hand I had work till closing the night
before and this was the next morning I
almost got fired a letter is crazy
writing a letter the level of white
woman that is to write a letter desk
wild yell
she's wild yo writing a letter
[ __ ] is when they have another
crazy polices our crews lunch orders
nobody allowed to eat fish they would
come hide on our stage to eat when they
want to be away from her yeah oh that's
great you still feel these are
reasonable say well you still standing
by they're reasonable will smell fish
all days Oh God you don't have to if you
don't have to it's just fantastic that
150 people if you coming into my office
and you got a chew gum cool I'm talking
to five people today 150 people want to
show and then I'm gonna this ones fire
right here an old friend worked on her
lot smiled and said good afternoon to
her one day and she became unhinged who
do you think you are you don't look at
me
yada-yada-yada this is real
ellen is not [ __ ] around bro come on
oh come on oh yeah where's the one there
was one foul last one where somebody's
gonna go to another job and then Ellen
like begs em like yo please stay don't
take this job they go to Ellen
respectfully and like drama takes other
jobs great opportunity whatever and I
was like please I need you please you've
got to stay with me whatever fire the
[ __ ] a week later no yeah it's there
somewhere I don't see it let me see if I
can go mine maybe it's in the first more
but that's wild but you know what this
is this is what it's like when you have
a girlfriend this word I think a lot of
people don't realize right it's like
we're shocked we're shocked that a woman
is capable of these things and know
under normal circumstances you should be
shocked right but then you realize that
she's a bull bull crash she's a bull
cracker right and when you're a bull
cracker you have to deal with a woman
and she flips [ __ ] right I don't
think Portia Rossi was just assuming
that ever she was cute what are you
swimming next to you pretty one of a set
I believe in beautiful
I don't believe in beautiful bull
crackers bounty they exist for real I am
so I heard that like beautiful bull
truck I heard this like ten years ago
from another Alex we're cool with you
know like they're all by every every
pretty lesbian is bisexual
if you're a beauty that disproven yeah
if you're a beautiful bull cracker
gorgeous bull cracker gorgeous beautiful
bull cracker is fun too yeah but if
you're like a bad [ __ ] beautiful bull
hundred percent lesbian I can't buy it
if you're a bad [ __ ] beautiful bull
crackers yeah yeah yeah if you're a
beautiful bad [ __ ] bull crap there's no
way there's no way you know what Ellen
is just Macaulay Culkin from home alone
grown up like if Macaulay Culkin what's
the name Macaulay Culkin yeah what's the
characters never McAlister sign up in
the counseling crackers name yeah I do
not know that but I think that yeah I
think she's just a grown up version of
that and that's fine and she's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you know what that's what it
is that's when you have to deal with
some annoying wife all day that's gonna
wear on you if you have to go home and
deal with your annoying wife who
probably has shitty ass breath okay
loves even fish all she doing is
correcting the wife [ __ ] at home at work
so she don't gotta deal with that at
work you gotta blame Portia de Rossi
Portia is that her name yeah I gotta see
this [ __ ] yeah she's pretty you're
pretty she's pretty bullcrap
she's pretty bull cracker you know what
I'm trying to find this story I can't
find it but is this funny [ __ ] yeah
she's in arrest develop yeah yeah she is
she ain't give me lesbian vibes when I
watch I don't think she is there you go
and then she had an Hesh another one she
flipped
smellin flips bitch's bra nah Ellen
maybe Tiger King Jesus [ __ ] Joe exotic
she's she's [ __ ] sure lesbian she's
Noel
lesbian no no this girl Portia neither
of them are lesbian Wow
yes Wow it all makes sense it all makes
sense now so your deal also Ellen is
stress B she's knows she says uh she
knows that she has a woman at home that
really isn't into her yeah she's into
the lifestyle she's into the power she's
into the opportunity that an Ellen can
give you but she's not really into you
so you're stressed that hurts you that's
Joe exotic yeah yeah it makes all of
sense
that's it Yoshii Yoshii office ourselves
then no she's not gonna off herself but
[Applause]